[Musique]
bonsoir à tous merci d'avoir choisi
France 3 la chaîne des élections
municipales pour cette première grande
soirée de débat en partenariat avec
France Bleu avant le premier tour se
sont en fait trois soirée
exceptionnelles que nous vous
proposerons afin de laisser place au
débat d'idées aux échanges d'arguments
au programme avec les différentes têtes
de liste avant la commune de Beaune en
Côte-d'Or place à notre premier débat
avec Auxerre dans l'Yonne un débat que
j'ai le plaisir d'animer avec Benoît
jacobot rédacteur en chef de France Bleu
Auxerre bonsoir Benoît bonsoir
Jean-Christophe bonsoir à tous aux
serres la préfecture de l'Yonne la ville
la plus peuplée du département avec
35000 habitants intramuros beaucoup de
Français la résument à son club de foot
la GIA mais Auxerre bien sûr ce n'est
pas que ça c'est un centre historique
médiéval avec ces maisons à port-de-bois
c'est une ville traversée par l'Yonne
avec sa cathédrale et son abbaye comme
point de repère c'est encore le
principal bassin d'emploi de l'Yonne la
vigne n'y est jamais très loin non plus
la ville est dirigée depuis 2001 par Guy
férèse qui brille un quatrième mandat et
si vous dites Auxerre on vous pardonnera
mais à l'évidence vous n'êtes pas de
lionne c'est exact alors pour ce débat
les principales têtes de liste sont avec
nous ce soir en direct sur notre antenne
différents bonsoir bonsoir vous êtes le
maire sortant donc candidat à votre
propre succession également conseiller
régional ancien membre du Parti
socialiste vous avez également le
soutien de la République en marche mais
vous présentez sans étiquette c'est
exact
vous êtes peut-être de liste les
républicains il y a encore quelques mois
vous étiez le maire de
Saint-Georges-sur-Baulche à côté
d'Auxerre vous vous présentez vous même
comme le candidat de la droite et du
centre c'est exact de niruacourt bonsoir
vous êtes l'une des deux têtes de liste
écologistes et citoyennes vous êtes
ancien adjoint au maire délégué à
l'environnement et sur votre liste vous
accueillez aussi des membres du parti
communiste de la gauche en général oui
bonne Navarre bonsoir bonsoir vous
dirigez l'autre liste écologiste de ce
scrutin les printemps pour Auxerre
investis par Europe Écologie Les Verts
vous étiez adjointe au maire chargé des
transports dans l'équipe municipale
sortante je précise qu'il y a trois
autres candidats à Auxerre Mourad youbis
sans étiquette on l'entendra un petit
peu plus tard dans ce débat
Pascal Roy pour le rassemblement
national Pascal Roy qui n'a pas souhaité
répondre à notre invitation enfin Franck
roux sans étiquette alors pour ce débat
on a choisi d'aborder avec vous certains
thèmes ce n'est pas le tout évidemment
du rôle du maire et de la vie de la
commune mais le premier thème que nous
faisons choisi et celui de
l'attractivité et du dynamisme
économique de la ville de cerf oui il
suffit de se balader dans les rues du
centre-ville pour le constater beaucoup
de boutiques restent vides pendant des
mois parfois pendant des années alors
que faire pour inverser la tendance je
me tourne vers vous
donc aujourd'hui Auxerre est dans est en
train de glisser dans un an d'éclat donc
au CRP des habitants Auxerre perd des
écoles Auxerre perd des emplois et
Auxerre perdent des commerces donc c'est
à dire que ce déclin donne une image
négative de la ville et donc la rend peu
attractive donc on a deux grands enjeux
pour essayer de redynamiser cette ville
essayer de faire revivre ce cœur de
ville et ces deux enjeux fondamentaux
c'est la déviation Sud pour permettre de
réaménager ce cœur de ville donc enlever
tous flux de transit c'est j'allais dire
c'est stratégique c'est le prérequis
avant toute réaménagement et le deuxième
c'est la connexion avec le Grand Paris à
travers la liaison ferroviaire voilà
donc on va parler mobilité transport
dans un deuxième temps dans ce débat on
sait bien que tout est lié cependant
cependant oui et j'insiste c'est toute
la difficulté d'un territoire c'est que
tous les enjeux sont imbriqués les uns
avec les autres donc il faut avoir une
capacité à avoir une approche
transversale des projets les uns avec
avec les autres et malheureusement dans
l'eau ces rois on a une fâcheuse
tendance à traiter les sujets les uns à
côté des autres voire isolément mais
quand on parle de vacances commerciales
vous vous répondez flux de circulation
avant les aménagements c'est le seul
problème sincèrement il y a des gens qui
pensent aujourd'hui que c'est en
augmentant l'offre qu'on va augmenter
les flux dans le centre-ville je pense
que c'est tout à fait l'inverse il faut
augmenter les flux et l'offre
naturellement s'adaptera et se
développera parce qu'avec le recul
différence vous ne vous dites pas j'ai
trop développé la zone commerciale des
Clairions parce que c'est ce qu'on peut
penser aujourd'hui je vais vous répondre
très clairement sur sur cette affaire
d'abord c'est une situation partagée par
de nombreuses villes et c'est pour ça
d'ailleurs que l'État a lancé un
programme qui s'appelle action cœur de
ville réserveau villeboyenne avec 5
milliards d'euros en faveur de ces
villes sur le commerce lui ben je veux
rappeler tout de même que je viens de
mettre en place il y a quelques mois
comme président de la communauté
d'agglomération un certain nombre
d'aides et de dispositifs pour permettre
je pense en particulier à la prise en
charge d'une partie du loyer parce qu'on
appelle des boutiques troubles pour
tester la réalité la viabilité que le
BIC de ces commerces des aides également
à l'investissement pour les travaux à
l'intérieur bien sûr de ces magasins des
aides aux associations mais surtout le
problème du cœur de ville pour moi il se
situe de la manière suivante le citoyen
et le consommateur est très largement
responsable de cela les secteurs
périmiques les zones commerciales comme
on dit c'est une révolution il y a 30
ans 40 ans il fallait le faire sinon
c'était l'évasion fiscal vers d'autres
villes ça n'est passé aujourd'hui mais
aujourd'hui c'est largement dépassé en
revanche vous savez quoi que ce qui fait
le plus grand dégât aujourd'hui c'est ce
qu'on appelle le commerce par le net un
chiffre et je maintiendrai là en 2019
100 milliards d'achats par le commerce
par internet ça veut dire que le
concitoyen soit peu paradoxaux ils
veulent des eaux de commercial parce
qu'ils
cancer nous nous avons inscrit dans
notre programme le projet doser plage
qui est un petit ensemble de bungalow
écologiques au bord de l'Yonne pour
valoriser notre bol de belles rivières
et donc c'est un moyen d'attirer
davantage de personnes sur notre
territoire d'attirer des touristes de
faire fonctionner aussi notre commerce
ça va redynamiser le centre-ville tout à
fait c'est aussi un moyen de redynamiser
le centre-ville on peut attirer du monde
à Auxerre grâce à ce moyen mais c'est
pas le seul nous avons aussi d'autres
propositions parmi les propositions que
nous avons c'est de venir en aide aux
commerçants qui en ont besoin
aujourd'hui donc en mettant en place
notamment un fonds d'investissement avec
des fonds publics et privés qui pourront
aider les commerces en à s'installer en
coeur de ville à faire des travaux
d'aménagement à faire des travaux de
rénovation Denis
c'est en fait c'est un projet global
qu'il faut relancer la ville il faut se
tourner vers les projets d'avenir il
faut relancer il faut que la ville soit
plus accessible on sait que par exemple
on en reparlera tout à l'heure la
mobilité et les endroits où les bus nous
notre projet aussi c'est de faire des
bus la gratuité des bus et les villes
qui l'ont déjà fait ils s'aperçoivent
que ça redynamise les villes c'est à
dire que à nouveau ils sont des jeunes
qui vont dans les centres-villes etc
c'est donc une vision globale en fait en
fait ce que nous ce qu'on propose en
fait c'est de faire de notre
agglomération un modèle de transition
écologique social et économique et pour
cela en fait il faut il faut pas en
rester au aux entreprises du passé en
fait il faut il faut aussi abandonner
alors je vais je vais aller plus loin
c'est pas que ce soit le casque pour la
surface du passé et ben en fait par
exemple un exemple je pense que il y a
des projets qui sont sans avenir il faut
il faut et qu'ils soient en plus
écologiquement nuisibles il faut les
abandonner que par exemple comme celui
de l'aérodrome branche Auxerre en fait
aujourd'hui couper 33 hectares de profit
pour profiter que quelques personnes
c'est vraiment des projets qui sont
inutiles je pense par contre ils sont
revenir à des activités qui sont en
adéquation avec notre territoire avec la
qualité de vie avec la qualité de vie et
ben par exemple nous on on va soutenir
les entreprises qui sont innovantes qui
forment des emplois utiles et non des
localisables c'est-à-dire je sais pas
l'agriculture biologique les circuits
courts l'économie tout ce qui tourne
autour de déchets l'économie circulaire
qu'on doit dire je les économie
circulaire les énergies renouvelables en
particulier en soutiendra les
entreprises qui sont participatives
c'est à dire que les citoyens passent
comme les toits solaires par exemple le
fait l'isolation thermique des bâtiments
c'est à dire il faut relancer toute une
économie après un espèce d'écosystème
dont vous étiez un métier non mais il y
a eu des bribes de transition mais
peut-être qu'il faut aller plus loin
maintenant aujourd'hui c'est pour ça
qu'on a fait une liste à part en fait
en bâtir du tourisme qui est à delaboré
social d'attractivité de la ville et de
vitalité du commerce j'ai mis en place
avec toi avec Denis et avec d'autres une
stratégie de développement touriste qui
porte ses fruits aujourd'hui donc là
dessus il y a vraiment pas de une
feuille de papier cigarette entre nous
de dire je t'écoute tous les sujets que
tu évoques là ils sont déjà engagés j'ai
envie de te dire une chose tu n'as pas
le bleu Paul de l'écologie
touristique effectivement il y a une
stratégie touristique qui a été mise en
place mais qui consiste aujourd'hui à
miser sur le développement du tourisme
fluvial pas seulement ce n'est pas vrai
en grande partie avec le projet
d'aménagement du port moi ce n'est pas
ce que je propose je pense que cette
stratégie de développement touristique
effectivement on peut avoir un port à
Auxerre mais par contre ce porc c'est
pas la sur ce port qu'on va faire venir
tous les touristes à Auxerre on a besoin
si je peux terminer on a besoin d'avoir
aujourd'hui on a des hôtels
principalement qui accueillent des
personnes pour une nuit de nuit etc on a
besoin de développer aussi des
hébergements qui soient un peu plus
longs quand on parle de serre-plage
c'est ça c'est ce projet les gens
peuvent venir les touristes peuvent
venir ils peuvent résider une semaine
deux semaines etc et ça on ne va pas
s'installer plus longtemps vous avez
évoqué la la proximité avec Paris
Auxerre aux portes de Paris beaucoup de
villes peuvent mettre cet argument en
avant
concrètement qu'est-ce que vous faites
pour vendre
vous avez commencé à parler de
l'attractivité du centre-ville et très
vite on a parlé de mobilité on a parlé
d'écologie on a parlé de tourisme donc
voyez bien qu'il y a une interaction
tout est liée donc il est très difficile
et je trouve que c'est c'est même
dangereux de toujours partir d'un projet
ou d'une de quelque chose de très micro
alors qu'un territoire c'est macro c'est
enchevêtrement et c'est la réussite de
faire coïncider tous ces enjeux tous ces
projets qui font que ce territoire
il y a aussi un tissu économique autour
très clairement il y a bassin de vie
mais on voudrait nous faire croire que
c'est une fatalité c'est la fatalité des
villes moyennes elles ont elles sont
destinées à péricliter et je dis non on
a quand même modeler on a un patrimoine
exceptionnel on a une situation
géographique on a des infrastructures
donc on a des choses à faire là et
j'allais dire quand même il faut vivre
avec notre temps certes il y a eu le
e-commerce mais une entreprise comme
Amazon aujourd'hui est en train de
développer des boutiques de proximité on
appelle ça le multicanal donc il faut
aussi appréhender toutes les évolutions
commerciales donc pourquoi pas du
multicanal à Auxerre il faut juste
essayer de travailler avec ces grandes
chaînes et en faire une force je
voudrais aussi dire quand même quand
même sur la la stratégie moi quand on me
dit qu'on a une stratégie touristique et
qu'on continue à déposer les touristes
en bas de la ville je me dis il faut
peut-être essayer de la faire évoluer
d'être un peu plus pragmatique et de
s'adapter aux besoins des touristes
c'est pas au tourisme de s'adapter à aux
besoins de la ville c'est la ville de
s'adapter aux besoins des touristes donc
on les déposerait plutôt en haut de la
ville et par exemple on pourrait leur
permettre d'aller aux toilettes avant
10h le matin ce qui est pas le cas
et puis répondez aussi à la question de
Benoît Jacobo finalement
cette ville d'Auxerre est-ce qu'elle se
fait pas d'amer le pion par d'autres
communes à proximité y compris ça
d'abord j'ai tout simplement dire à
Christian Bero que Silda que ça comme
proposition pour redonner de
l'attractivité la ville ça va il y a pas
de souci à se faire ce que je vais dire
d'abord c'est que il faut les uns les
autres prendre la mesure du Devil qui
est une ville dynamique vous l'avez
souligné vous-même
l'océro a plus exactement c'est le
premier bassin d'emploi du département
j'aime bien rappeler quand même que la
population de la communauté
d'agglomération parce qu'on raisonne
ambassade de vie ses 18 à 19% de la
population du département mais c'est 30%
des emplois c'est 36 000 emplois très
exactement et de dire raccourt a raison
il y a des activités qui ont disparu
d'autres les ont remplacés et quand je
dis 36000 ans passés pas du tout le fait
du hasard c'est parce qu'avant 2008
avant la crise c'était déjà 36000 ans
pas on l'a toujours cette 36000 emplois
et ça signifie oui
c'est pas quelque chose qu'on fait s'il
nous reste un peu d'argent etc
aujourd'hui il y a une urgence
écologiste et les observois qu'on a
rencontrés pendant cette campagne ils
sont prêts à la transition écologique
maintenant effectivement on va en parler
dans quelques minutes et non mais donc
il faut s'appuyer là-dessus c'est-à-dire
il y a une forte poussée de certaines
activités qui de qualité qui ont du sens
qui redonne du sens aussi à la vie en
ville et et ça je pense que il faut
partir de ça quoi il faut pas repart
revoir la ville comme autrefois là on
est d'accord là-dessus effectivement il
y a des activités qu'on pourra qu'on
peut plus faire aujourd'hui il faut se
souvenir les activités d'avenir quoi en
fait et en fait les activités qui sont
innovantes ils sont déjà à moitié à 50%
qui sont déjà autour de l'environnement
un projet de réaménagement qui est dans
les cartons qui est en gestation depuis
depuis le début du mandat c'est celui de
la de la place des Cordeliers si vous
êtes élu maire est-ce que vous le menez
à son terme ou vous y apporter des
modifications la place des Cordeliers
qui est donc la place centrale de serre
alors effectivement quand on parle
d'attra activités et voilà un moyen là
aussi de redonner de l'attractivité à
notre cœur de ville en ayant ce
qu'aujourd'hui nous n'avons pas
aujourd'hui quand on regarde les places
la plupart des places d'Auxerre elle
s'est occupées par du stationnement par
des voitures et donc avoir une belle
place publique qui soit accessible pour
des lieux de rencontre des lieux de
convivialité des lieux de commerce avec
des terrasses de café etc voilà un beau
projet alors effectivement ce projet a
été engagé sur la question des
Cordeliers mais il faut qu'on mène ce
projet en ayant une meilleure
concertation en demandant aux
oscarroises et aux océros à ce qu'ils
veulent faire sur cette place et
engagement vraiment une discussion avec
les vidéos
municipales là vous avez certainement un
projet pour cette place des Cordeliers
non bah moi j'ai le projet qui est celui
de toute écologiste c'est-à-dire d'en
faire une place piétonne mais je ne le
ferai pas contre pas forcément un
parking enterré mais je ne le ferai pas
contre la volonté des osaroises et des
ossarois c'est-à-dire que si ce n'est
pas volonté si leur décision n'est pas
celle là je respecterai voilà c'est ça
qui est important aujourd'hui c'est
d'avoir une écologie incitative mais pas
une écologie qui va brusquer les gens
qui va les braquer il faut faire avec
les gens et pas contre eux
et ce centre ville
c'est pour ça que j'avais les Cordeliers
il y avait la place des Cordeliers et
nous c'était justement c'est une des
motifs que c'est avancait pas assez vite
quoi en fait les Cordeliers c'est très
important c'est vraiment le centre de la
ville effectivement nous on est d'accord
sur un certain nombre de choses il faut
en faire un lieu convivial avec un
verdissement etc des terrasses de café
etc et je vous signale que nous on a
pris ça très au sérieux puisque le 4
mars en fait une soirée avec un cabinet
d'avocat qui viendra présenter ce que
nous on souhaiterait pour les Cordeliers
c'est pas très compliqué pour moi en
bâtir je considère que les aménagements
publics et notamment des places c'est un
élément essentiels de l'attractivité des
coeurs de ville et donc j'ai trois
projets majeurs et pour ça que les
places de Cordeliers n'a pas été raillée
jusqu'à présent il fallait que je trouve
une solution pour le stationnement je
l'ai trouvé c'est déménagement de l’élo
sa vigile avec un parti de jardin le
deuxième sujet c'est le marché de
l'arcubus la place de l'Arquebuse et pas
seulement le marché j'ai présenté
d'ailleurs le projet de AD et de marché
aux commerçant la semaine dernière j'ai
tenu le calendrier je tenais et puis il
filait ce sera de la place d'école je ne
peux pas faire la place des Cordeliers
si auparable je n'ai pas réalisé
l'aménagement du parc du jardin de
l'étang sa vigile alors justement on
vous propose de passer à la deuxième
thématique de de ce débat avec les
transports et la mobilité vous avez
commencé en parler on parle de ce centre
ville on peut peut-être s'intéresser à
la question de la piétonnisation par
exemple est-ce que vous avez
l'impression que c'est l'avenir que sur
ma route
je crois qu'on a trois candidats qui
globalement veulent extraire la voiture
du centre-ville là-dessus on est
d'accord et on a un candidat qui pense
que l'avenir du centre-ville passe
encore par un parking hyper centre c'est
un projet qui a 40 ans Jean-Pierre
Soissons par les déjà d'un parking hyper
centre à Auxerre et de penser ce qui
était vrai il y a 40 ans aujourd'hui va
sauver le cœur de ville sur la
fréquentation je me dis que ça manque
d'ambition ça manque de vision et on
prépare pas du tout préparé l'avenir de
ce territoire donc oui je pense qu'il
faut vraiment essayer d'extraire la
voiture du centre-ville végétaliser les
places essayez de d'améliorer la
sécurisation des cheminements piétons
parce qu'aujourd'hui vous ne pouvez pas
circuler dans les rues d'Auxerre la
cohabitation piéton voiture est
impossible et je redis vous ne pouvez
pas envisager un tel réaménagement sans
avoir la certitude que la déviation Sud
se fasse et aujourd'hui concernant ce
plan de financement le seul la seule
partie qui est financée c'est
l'acquisition foncière donc il faut à
tout prix qu'on fasse avancer ce dossier
là et je je dis que c'est c'est un
prérequis c'est vous pouvez faire tout
ce que vous voulez si on n'a pas la
certitude que ce projet là aboutisse une
bonne fois pour toute vous pourrez faire
tout ce que vous voudrez la la la les
voiries et sous la voie est sous
dimensionnée et donc la ville est
congestionnée il fait sur le
contournement sud de serre qu'est-ce que
peut faire un maire à part attendre
j'écoutais attentivement créer son
barreau visiblement il le maîtrise pas
le dossier tout à fait être clair
dans le calendrier
au cours du prochain trimestre nous
connaîtrons le projet définitif ça c'est
clair le projet définitive du
contournement qu'est-ce qui se passe en
ce moment les acquisuno foncières sont
au cours dès cette année diffuse
archéologiques vont avoir lieu le rebord
rebond qui va permettre de préciser dans
ses acquisitions foncières se poursuit
jusqu'en 2022 ça signifie quoi ça
signifie que le projet va être prêt et
ça signifie aussi et j'ai un courrier de
madame wargon qui est secrétaire d'État
auprès du ministère de l'écologie pardon
pas de l'argon dit très clairement que
ce projet a été à vocation à être
financé dans le prochain contrat de plan
état région voilà quelle est la réalité
aujourd'hui et tout ce qui est dit
autour c'est de la daturisme et ça va
strictoque et on va pas entendre
attendre plus que le contre Le Mans soit
terminé pour travailler sur le coeur de
ville ça peut le monde à l'envers ça
peut le serpent qui se mord la queue
donc il faut conduire
ce contournement sud de serre on est
pour ça
parce qu'en fait ça ça dévié un flux de
35000 véhicules jours qui traversent la
ville sans s'y arrêter donc
effectivement il y avait il y a eu un
vote je crois des conseils de quartier
de l'Auxerrois qui nous a fait prendre
cette position là parce que les
écologistes en général ils sont pas très
favorables mais à la nuit des conseils
de quartier il y avait une gêne quoi
enfin sur toute la ville ça bloquait
toute la ville je pense qu'il faut pas
faire que ça il faut aussi offrir aux
personnes qui viennent travailler à
Auxerre ou faire des achats l'occasion
en fait de parking relais au nord et au
sud de la ville qui leur permettrait en
fait de de laisser leur voiture et de
venir avec des navettes électriques
gratuites au centre parce que c'est un
tiers des voitures dans l'observois qui
sont en fait ce qu'on appelle des
pendulaires qui viennent juste
travailler qui repartent etc donc ça il
faut l'aménager et puis en fait nous
notre proposition c'est aussi il faut
offrir aux observois d'autres mobilités
notre projet en fait c'est d'aller vers
la gratuité parce que les cinquantaine
de villes en France qu'il a mis et on
part par SWAT c'est une réussite en fait
que le nombre de gens qui prennent le
bus augmentent beaucoup et tout à
l'heure j'en avais parlé ça redonneuse
les villes et c'est ça redonne du sens
c'était un choix politique et humain et
c'est une mesure sociale pour les
familles je pense que c'est vraiment si
on veut des enclaver le centre-ville il
faut plusieurs solutions c'est pas une
seule solution
est-ce qu'il y a des différences
finalement avec le programme de de votre
confrère écologiste en face oui oui il y
a des différences je voudrais juste
revenir avant sur le fait sur cette
déviation Sud effectivement elle est
attendue des osaroises et des ossawa
depuis très longtemps c'est un projet
qui leur tient à cœur et je voudrais
juste rappeler une petite anecdote de
2015 sur le précédent contrat plan état
région il me semble qu'à cette époque
l'État était déjà par temps pour nous
submer mais que par contre c'est la
région qui n'a pas suivi donc ce n'est
pas parce qu'aujourd'hui effectivement
l'état dit qu'il est
que la région va suivre pour autant
ceci dit ceci dit bon voilà on est tous
d'accord globalement pour dire que la
déviation sud elle c'est une nécessité
des transports en commun moi
personnellement je ne suis pas favorable
au tout gratuit c'est une fausse bonne
idée il y a beaucoup de spécialistes
aujourd'hui de l'urbanisme et des
transports qui expliquent que le bus
gratuit entièrement gratuit en fait sa
concurrence ça ne permet pas de limiter
la circulation automobile en ville sa
concurrence directement qui sa
concurrence les piétons et sa
concurrence les vélos parce que les gens
au lieu de se déplacer à pied il se
déplace en bus au lieu de se déplacer en
vélo ils prennent le bus puisque c'est
gratuit donc moi ce que si je peux aller
jusqu'au bout de ce que de mes
propositions ce que nous proposons la
liste les printemps pour au Cercle que
je mène c'est une gratuité modérée c'est
à dire pour qui d'abord en priorité pour
les plus jeunes pour les moins de 18 ans
en priorité parce que ce sont eux qu'il
faut habitués pour apprendre les
transports en commun donc pour les
scolaires et aujourd'hui c'est une forme
d'inégalité que nous avons sur notre
territoire parce que les transports
scolaires sont gratuits pour les élèves
qui viennent de la région qui sont
transportés par la région par contre ils
sont payants pour ceux qui sont
transportés par la communauté de le
savoir donc ça c'est une chose
importante à mettre en place la gratuité
pour les scolaires et les moins de 18
ans autre chose importante aussi c'est
améliorer la fréquence des bus à Auxerre
avoir une seconde ligne à haute à haut
niveau de fréquence et puis les
déplacements piétons c'est aussi quelque
chose de très important et de ce point
de vue à Océane nous avions un très joli
projet qui était mené par la Jeune
chambre économique qui avait un projet
de signalétique qui est ce projet là
c'est un beau projet qu'il faut
absolument soutenir et encourager à
l'avenir
elle est particulièrement adaptée au
villes moyennes enfin aujourd'hui les
indices ils vont là dessus c'est ça
bouge beaucoup dans ce domaine là vous
avez répondu différence répond également
avec
la gratuité ça n'existe pas il y a
toujours quelqu'un qui paye et en
l'occurrence sur un budget 6500000 euros
le budget était transport de la Gobi
communauté d'agglomération
quasiment 70% payé par les entreprises
donc il faut le savoir ça veut dire que
ça à coup et plus vous voudrez aller
ouvert la gratuité ou le développement
ça veut dire fera bien que quelqu'un
paye et notamment la communauté de clos
apporte support pardon le défi
sur le contournement sujet
la région d'environnement la région va
rentrer dans le dispositif parce que la
région par obligation a été obligée de
réaliser ce qu'on appelle un schéma
régional des infrastructures routières
et c'est cela qui ouvre la voie au
financement d'une partie de ce contour
de moi par la région et j'ajoute et
j'entends rien encore une fois c'est
important la région prévoit dans sa
prospective financière et dans le cas
que j'évoquais tout à l'heure le contrat
de plan à partir de 2002 la région
prévoit 22 millions d'euros récent Marot
vous avez parlé du rapprochement entre
serre et Paris forcément on peut penser
au train alors vous vous n'êtes ni la
SNCF ni la région concrètement qu'est-ce
que un maire peut faire
pour faciliter la vie des usagers et
déterminer voyez on prend l'exemple de
la déviation sud on est en train de nous
dire que dans sa prospective financière
la région a inscrit ou va inscrire 22
millions d'euros la ville d'Auxerre a
inscrit zéro c'est pas vrai c'est ça qui
est marrant
c'est cette image qu'on donne du
territoire il faut montrer sa volonté il
faut l'inscrire mais si je suis désolé
monsieur donc et c'est toute la
difficulté tant qu'on fera semblant tant
qu'on fera des faux-semblants les gens
auront toujours un doute et donc ce
qu'il faut c'est vraiment être déterminé
en disant on va mettre les moyens de
liaison ferroviaire et Paris
électrification
une personne toute seule a décidé de
refuser l'électrification sans même
consulter les habitants concernés par
cette desserte ferroviaire on est pour
on est contre mais quand même vous voyez
qu'on a un problème de démocratie sur ce
territoire
donc aujourd'hui c'est très très clair
on est en voie unique donc ça pose une
vraie problématique de cadence donc il
faut dédoubler les voies et ensuite il
faut essayer de développer une offre
ferroviaire donc on peut travailler avec
le département essayer de faire des
liaisons directes améliorer améliorer le
temps de trajet et justement redevenir
connecté à ce grand bassin parisien et
essayer de faire venir des habitants
différents
il a fini par quitter la communauté
d'agglomération il a été élu local il
devrait suivre les dossiers la ville a
délibéré la communauté d'agglomération
au délibéré pour mettre 22 billions et
demi d'euros dans le contour de mon Sud
première chose deuxième chose sur le
train ce n'est pas moi le train c'est
une commission nationale et les
propositions de refus d'électrification
sur l'ensemble du territoire ont été
validés par la ministre des Transports
volonté politique qu'est-ce que vous lui
répondez
ensuite par exemple s'il existe encore
aujourd'hui c'est parce que ces boîtes
il est permis et sur le train abandon de
l'électrification on est d'accord pas
d'accord bon il fallait que je trouve
une solution et j'ai trouvé une solution
aussi avec la région avec ses trains qui
sont les trains hydrogène parce que
demain il y aura plus de train diesel il
fallait trouver une alternative à
l'électrification et quand on parle
d'écologie de développement durable
d'hydrogènes vertes
c'est quelque chose qui peut
complètement
le territoire auxerrois ça peut lui ça
va être un territoire innovant ça va
créer des tout un tas d'entreprises qui
va s'occuper d'hydrogène et en fait le
transhydrogène c'est quoi c'est des
trains électriques c'est seulement une
pile à combustible qui permet au train
de voir les plus longtemps mais c'est
cette technique là quoi donc
effectivement nous on est favorable à
l'innovation et donc hydrogène au départ
c'était des bus à hydrogène c'est ça
un mot mais vraiment un mot parce que
vous avez un peu d'avance sur votre
temps de parole oui sur la question de
l'hydrogène c'est un beau projet
effectivement mais à mon avis il ne faut
pas miser que sur ce projet car c'est
prendre un risque pour l'avenir de notre
territoire voilà et ce qui est important
aussi c'est de restaurer les liaisons
directes en train que nous avions à
destination de Paris et de Dijon il y en
a beaucoup moins ces derniers temps et
ça on en avait beaucoup plus avant c'est
important de le garder sur notre
territoire troisième partie thématique
de notre débat ce soir toujours en
direct sur France 3 avec France Bleu la
santé et l'environnement de
préoccupations qui dans toutes les
enquêtes d'opinion arrivent en tête des
préoccupations des Français donc
également des océros oui Jean-Christophe
si vous essayez de prendre par exemple
un rendez-vous chez l'ophtalmo ça peut
être très compliqué à Auxerre alors on
sait tous qu'il faut inciter les les
professionnels les médecins à
s'installer sur le territoire mais
comment c'est toute la question de
miracourt en fait c'est une très bonne
question parce que beaucoup de gens se
la poussent à Auxerre pour trouver un
médecin un dentiste etc je signale je
l'appelle que le nombre de médecins il
est passé de 38 à 18 à peu près 15 ans
en 2005 un médecin au ces rois il avait
à peu près 1000 patients et devait
s'occuper de mille patients aujourd'hui
le même médecin il devrait il devrait
avoir en charge 1900 patients ça devient
ça devient impossible alors nous notre
proposition notre proposition qui est
vraiment déjà bien engagé c'est de nous
travaillons avec la Fédération Nationale
pour la mise en place d'un centre de
santé
pluridisciplinaire avec des médecins et
du personnel soignant salarié ça ça
semble peut-être bizarre comme ça mais
en fait ce dispositif ce dispositif il a
fait ses preuves il attire des jeunes
médecins qui arrivent à un sondage 70%
des jeunes médecins ils préfèrent
travailler en équipe ils préfèrent un
emploi salarial parce que ça leur permet
de concilier leur vie professionnelle et
leur vie familiale la compétence de la
mairie vous pensez ah ben non c'est
fournir les lieux où effectivement les
bâtiments etc après après les paiements
ils se font exactement comme quand on va
chez un médecin oui mais c'est des
salariés en fait c'est un remboursement
qui se fait exactement comme un autre
médecin sauf que là c'est effectivement
le la structure qui qui les paie qui
encaisse les remboursements cresson
Marot on sort le le tapis rouge ou le
carnet de chèque pour les médecins les
deux non donc on serait plutôt favorable
pour une maison des internes et des
professionnels de santé donc des
structures pour accueillir les
professionnels de santé dans notre
territoire pour qu'ils puissent exercer
exercer en libéral en salariat dans des
hôpitaux privés au public et il faut
également aussi préparer la relève parce
que aujourd'hui on n'a pas assez de
médecins donc là c'est c'est factuel
encore une fois donc il faut essayer de
préparer d'anticiper ceux qui vont finir
par leurs études et donc justement de
leur donner une bonne image du
territoire encore une fois moi je
regarde toujours Paris je suis désolé
mais se connecter avec Paris leur donner
la possibilité de finir leur internat
dans l'Yonne éventuellement de leur
donner une très belle image du
territoire et leur donner envie de
s'installer pour qu'ensuite bah ils
puissent venir exercer dans notre
territoire parce que sinon si on prépare
pas sensibiliser la future génération de
médecins elle va continuer à passer tout
le temps et pas s'arrêter oui je le
constat on peut tous partager le
bêtement ça en ajoutant d'ailleurs deux
choses et je reviens après vraiment sur
du sur du concret tant que les médecins
auront la liberté d'installation ça se
passera comme ça pour une large
deuxièmement le du virus clausus qui
était bloqué par définition a été
ouverte pour forber habite 5 il faut peu
près 10 ans aujourd'hui en raison de
effets de l'ancien du virus clausus
il y a plus de médecins aujourd'hui qui
partent de retraite que de Bessa qui
s'installe bien nous pouvons agir moi
j'ai ouvert effectivement avec les aides
publiques j'ai ouvert une maison de
santé dans un quartier d'Auxerre qui est
la rive droite et qui fonctionne plutôt
très bien il y a un deuxième
centre qui va s'ouvrir et ça c'est un
travail commun l'Office s'envoi de
l'habitat le bailleur social des HLM le
département et la ville et c'est un
centre de santé plus axé si vous voulez
en direction des gens situation de
précarité et je travaille sur un
troisième pôle avec l'hôpital parce que
je souhaite installer à côté de
l'hôpital ou dans l'hôpital un centre de
santé qui lui sera adossé aux techniques
aux technologies et aux compétences et
praticiens de l'hôpital et puis j'ajoute
aussi que dans mon projet j'ai la
volonté de créer une maison non pas
seulement des internes parce que
l'hôpital nous avons investi pour
accueillir les internes dans un très
beau bâtiment de très beaux logements
aussi pour accueillir des médecins qui
pourraient venir de jour 3 jours par
semaine voilà en réalité ce que nous
pouvons faire lorsque nous sommes des
élus locaux votre avis sur la question
et
seconde petite question l'hôpital de
serre effectivement est-ce qu'on peut
lui venir en aide sachant qu'il est très
endetté effectivement il y a d'une part
de problèmes à Auxerre d'une part donc
le problème de l'hôpital qui est endetté
et d'autre part la médecine de ville qui
souffre aussi parce qu'il y a beaucoup
de médecins qui partent en retraite et
qui ne sont pas remplacés donc créer des
maisons médicales des maisons de santé
etc c'est une démarche intéressante mais
c'est une démarche qui n'est pas
suffisante parce que ça ne garantit pas
pour autant installation de médecins il
est important sur ce type de problème
qui concerne tous les toutes les
océroises et tous les océros d'agir avec
des élus qui sont volontaires et qui
entreprennent vraiment une démarche pour
aller chercher des médecins des
étudiants en médecine que ce soit à
Paris ou à Dijon pour les convaincre de
venir s'installer sur notre territoire
et moi ce que j'aimerais faire si les
électeurs votent pour nous le 15 mars
prochain c'est mettre en place un
système de bourse d'études pour les
internes en médecine la ville
volontairement puisqu'elle a la clause
de compétences général s'engage à
financer tout ou partie des études des
médecins en échange de ce financement
les médecins s'engagent à venir
s'installer sur notre territoire et à
exercer pendant un certain nombre
d'années un mot sur l'environnement s'il
vous plaît je sais qu'il y a on a plus
que 5 minutes alors je vous demande de
passer à l'environnement vous pourrez
bien sûr parler de santé également sur
l'environnement
tout le monde tout le monde sur son
programme a des belles clauses sur
l'environnement mieux vivre mieux
respirer etc est-ce que concrètement les
municipalités peuvent faire quelque
chose si oui quoi
déjà et maintenant il faut aller donc on
a créé j'ai créé un parlement de lot
d'auxerrois avec une avec des élus des
agriculteurs des associations etc il
faut qu'ils l'utilisent parce que
évidemment maintenant j'étais viré donc
il fonctionne pas il fonctionne plus
mais j'avais obtenu de l'Agence de l'eau
en fait la mise en expérimentation dans
l'observatoire des pseud PSE ça veut
dire des paiements pour service
environnementaux en fait il faut aider
les agriculteurs à faire leur transition
au niveau de du bio parce qu'en fait
comment dire la culture bio
l'agriculture bio c'est la seule qui est
exemple donc d'intrant effectivement
une autre qualité à la source donc je
pense que il faut absolument passer par
cette qualité de l'eau il faut aussi
dans nos choix on a parlé du 100%
d'alimentation bio et locale dans les
restaurants scolaires ça aussi ça fait
partie de la prévention au niveau de la
santé en fait parce qu'en fait on sait
bien les chercheurs aujourd'hui ils font
bien ce lien entre la qualité de
environnement et puis les gens qui
vivent dans cet environnement crémant
écologie et développement économique ça
va bien ensemble c'est ce qu'on appelle
le développement durable mais donc moi
je crois à l'inexpression qui a souvent
été donc je crois l'économie circulaire
donc du pain du parc du principe que les
déchets des impôts peuvent être les
matières premières des autres donc il
faut vraiment qu'on essaie de mener une
politique de sensibilisation sur la
valorisation des déchets entre autres
sur le tri sélectif puisque on a un
territoire où on a quand même un bon
taux de tri sélectif et donc il faudrait
qu'on puisse aboutir faire aboutir une
filière industrielle qui puisse
éventuellement utiliser ce tri sélectif
donc
je pense c'est une question encore une
fois ce qu'il disait Maud une question
de volonté impolitique
pour vous aussi comme pour devenir roi
court on imagine les écologistes de ce
tour de table est-ce qu'il y a une
mesure qui vous semble essentielle
aujourd'hui à Auxerre et qui peut être
mise en place finalement par la
municipalité en matière d'environnement
et bien pas forcément par la
municipalité parce que aujourd'hui cette
compétence de l'écologie c'est une
compétence intercommunale mais
effectivement il y a un dossier qui moi
me préoccupe beaucoup à Auxerre et dans
l'otarrois c'est cette question de la
qualité de l'eau et de ce point de vue
on a vu encore ces dernières semaines il
y a eu des pollutions de l'eau au
nitrates voilà et ça il faut accompagner
les agriculteurs alors il faut les
accompagner il y a eu des choses qui ont
été mises en place jusqu'à maintenant
comme l'association de la plaine du sol
pour la qualité de l'eau c'est très bien
mais on ne va pas assez loin on ne va
pas assez fort sur ses propos sur ses
projets justement pour protéger notre
qualité de l'eau et ça c'est quelque
chose de très important c'est pourquoi
nous les printemps pour Auxerre nous
proposons justement d'y aller beaucoup
plus fort d'inciter davantage les
agriculteurs à se convertir au bio en
mettant en place une prime pour la
conversion au bio des agriculteurs qui
travaillent à proximité des points de
capteurs
je veux rassurer modaveur qui
visiblement là aussi par Benoît
des dossiers puisque j'ai trouvé un
accord avec le mot de l'agriculture et
le monde de la viticulture pour la mise
en place de la charte sur l'eau et d'ici
par le Parlement dont j'avais confié la
présidente de lit mais qui depuis est
parti c'est pas vrai qu'il est qu'il est
viré et j'ai trouvé aussi d'accord avec
l'agence de bassin pour permettre
l'accompagnement des agriculteurs y
compris sur le plan financier ça y est
beau c'est réglé parce que j'ai répondu
à l'appel à projet et c'est avec un
double objectif zéro nitrates
et puis également
moi de produits phytosanitaires ça y est
les accords sont trouvés ce qui a été
mis en place c'est une rémunération pour
les services pour la qualité
environnementale c'est-à-dire qu'on va
donner une prime aux agriculteurs qui
vont rendre des services pour
l'environnement mais ce que je propose
ce n'est pas ça parce que ça ça
entretient les agriculteurs dans un état
de dépendance à l'égard de la
collectivité ce qui est important c'est
que les agriculteurs puissent dignement
de leur exploitation et c'est pour ça
qu'il faut une prime pour les aider à
passer à un autre système agricole
j'ai dit faut déjà discuter avec eux
parce que quand vous les rencontrez ils
sont un peu bousculés donc on prend des
arrêtés antispicides on leur a encore
amenuise leur revenu et je suis désolé
vous l'avez plus les retirer
et pour répondre aux agriculteurs je
fais encore de l'administration je nomme
un vice-président donc là franchement
c'est sûr qu'on va avancer sur le
dossier donc tout simplement vous allez
pouvoir vous exprimer encore dans
quelques instants mais ce débat touche à
sa fin ça va être donc le moment de
votre minute de conclusion une minute
libre pour vous adresser aux électeurs à
sablier virtuel ses graines ras derrière
nous et à côté de vous durant 60
secondes votre ordre de passage a été
désigné par tirage au sort avant ce
débat mais tout d'abord on va donner une
minute à quelqu'un qui n'a pas pu être
avec nous alors qu'il le souhaitait
Mourad Youbi tête de liste sans
étiquette qui nous dit pourquoi lui il a
souhaité s'engager dans cette campagne à
Auxerre
j'ai souhaité être candidat à l'élection
municipale à Auxerre pour plusieurs
raisons la première raison c'était pour
un carnet le renouveau avec une liste de
personnes jeunes dynamiques
issue de la société civile et surtout à
politique la deuxième raison c'était
aussi pour
mettre la lumière sur les quartiers
populaires qui ont été délaissés depuis
une vingtaine d'années et la troisième
raison c'était aussi pour proposer une
offre politique nouvelle qui
sortent de l'ordinaire et qui soit loin
des parties traditionnelles la partie
politique traditionnelle et le dernier
point aussi c'était parce que nouvelle
génération
issue des quartiers qui a plutôt bien
réussi et qui est parfaitement intégré à
souhaiter que je puisse mener une liste
afin de porter des idées et puis parce
qu'il y avait un intérêt de l'action
publique et c'est là qui est né cette
liste que je mène qui s'appelle Auxerre
pour un avenir meilleur c'était donc
Morad Youbi Candida sans étiquette
création Marot c'est donc à vous vous
avez une minute pour pour conclure et
bien en conclusion je voudrais faire
partager aux asseoirs mon ma vision sur
l'avenir de la ville je voudrais faire
Auxerre une ville dynamique qui crée des
emplois je voudrais faire d'Auxerre une
ville sur où on puisse garantir la
sécurité je voudrais faire dosser une
ville propre où on puisse on puisse
protéger l'environnement je voudrais
également faire d'Auxerre une ville
remarquable pour faire rayonner son
patrimoine en s'appuyant sur les
nouvelles technologies l'innovation je
pense que c'est important avec une
équipe
une vraie équipe une équipe diverses
qui représente tous les quartiers de la
ville compétences qui a beaucoup
d'expérience et avec beaucoup de
détermination on veut inverser cette
fameuse courbe du déclin du territoire
au cerveau merci merci
à vous adressez-vous aux électeurs des
15 et 22 mars prochain pourquoi
doivent-ils voter pour vous top départ
effectivement je m'adresse aux observois
pour que qu'ils prennent bien le temps
de leur décision aujourd'hui les
scientifiques nous ont alerté ils nous
donnent une douzaine d'années pour
réparer nos erreurs l'urgence écologique
urgence sociale sont devenus des
réalités tout le monde le constate vous
le savez enfin tout le monde le sait en
plus l'orientation on pourrait dire
l'orientation Léo libéral de la
présidence Macron elle accentue nos
difficultés alors nous nous ce qu'on
vous propose en fait c'est de répondre à
ce double défi en faisant du mandat
municipal 2020-2027 une période de
transition écologique et sociale
accélérée nous devons agir être
ambitieux et agir vite alors nous nous
sommes une liste et nous sommes une
liste cit nous avons fait le choix de ne
pas le revendiquer l'étiquette de parti
politique pour être pour avoir des
orientations pour être libre de nos
orientations nous sommes des femmes et
des hommes écologiques de sensibilité
écologique et de gauche c'est terminé
pour conclure et peut-être qu'on vaincre
les électeurs et bien je voudrais
m'adresser simplement ce soir aux
Auxerre Waze et aux océros qui nous
regardent et leur dire que le 15 mars
prochain leur bulletin de vote peut
faire la différence s'il souhaite
aujourd'hui une équipe renouvelée une
équipe motivée une équipe déterminée qui
apporte un souffle nouveau pour notre
commune alors il faut choisir sans
aucune hésitation la liste les printemps
pour Auxerre c'est la liste qui porte
des enjeux fondamentaux pour aujourd'hui
pour notre commune comme l'écologie
comme la démocratie participative ou
encore des questions essentielles pour
nous la santé c'est pourquoi il faut
voter les printemps pour Auxerre en mars
prochain
merci 10 Thérèse votre minute je veux
dire aux océans quelque chose de très
simple dans un monde qui suscite de
l'inquiétude de l'anxiété parfois de
l'angoisse et bien j'ai tout simplement
votre leur dire que Auxerre c'est une
commune de T2 destin pour reprendre ce
que disait Audrey
et cette communauté a besoin de repères
elle a besoin de s'appuyer à la fois sur
de l'expérience sur de la solidité je
suis avec une une vision de la ville qui
est tout simplement une vision qui vise
à rassembler et permettre à chacune à
chacun d'être accompagné par la ville
tout au long de sa vie depuis sa
naissance jusqu'à l'automne de sa vie et
c'est comme ça je crois qu'il faut dire
aussi aux oscerrois l'aventure pourrait
être dommageable pour Auxerre parce que
dans ces temps d'incertitudes l'aventure
n'est pas forcément le meilleur ticket
pour l'avenir merci pour cette minute de
conclusion et merci à tous d'avoir
accepté ce débat à présent place au
choix des électeurs les 15 et 22 mars
restez avec nous tout de suite place à
notre seconde débat de la soirée avec
les candidats à la mairie de Beaune en
Côte-d'Or ils seront 5 dans un instant à
votre place madame messieurs pour la
suite de notre soirée électorale
[Musique]